joël labbé sénateur écologiste du
morbihan elle joue elle l'avait bonsoir
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur rt france un rapport on vient
de le voir alarmant donc qu'est ce qui
vous a marqué à la lecture de ce
document est bien marquée non j'ai pas
été surpris parce que l'année dernière
mes collègues ronan dantec et jean yves
roux ont établi un rapport sur
l'adaptation au dérèglement climatique
et et bien je retrouve les mêmes lignes
au moins pour moi personnellement
j'étais préparé à savoir il est
important d'être lucide la situation est
très préoccupante c'est important de le
dire à nos populations pas tomber dans
le catastrophisme mais il y a lieu et de
s'adapter et de prendre les mesures pour
atténuer ces phénomènes sera ce
phénomène de dérèglement climatique
alors les inondations sont les
événements climatiques les plus
fréquents comment selon vous protéger
les populations ces catastrophes alors
protégé c'est s'adapter parce que ces
catastrophes
elles vont se poursuivre parce qu'une
partie du mal est fait et bien alors
c'est beaucoup de mal a été fait du fait
de l'arasement des talus afin de
l'artificialisation des sols déjà ça il
faut il faut stopper cela remettre en
place des défenses des talus fait tout
ce qui permet de re titre de retenir
l'eau est de faire en sorte que les
événements ne soit pas cataclysme is
cataclysmique pour les populations
donc là on est dans l'adaptation et en
parallèle il faut prendre des mesures
d'atténuation parce que on sait que à la
trajectoire de deux degrés actuellement
pour 2000 pour 2050 nous va nous mettre
dans une situation particulièrement
préoccupante ces événements vont devenir
de plus en plus fréquentes relais puis
forte les grandes périodes de sécheresse
l'été avec les risques d'incendié chez
nous aussi c'est prévu prévisible
si on n'y prend pas garde et à l'horizon
2080 la situation deviendrait carrément
alarmante donc il faut vraiment prendre
les mesures et comme je le disais
adaptation d'une part atténuation
d'autre part et cela d'une façon
simultanée
alors le rapport indique un que sont les
vagues de chaleur qui ont été les plus
mortels alors que ce sont les événements
climatiques les moins nombreux là aussi
quelles solutions peut-on mettre en
place le rôle de l'état ou est ce que
c'est à chacun d'entre nous d'agir
le rôle de l'état est essentiel le rôle
des pouvoirs publics et en même temps
que de que d'en poser quelque part des
mesures communiquer avec la population
pour qu'elle comprenne c'est l'intérêt
de tout le monde de prendre de prendre
ces mesures alors sur la question par
exemple du réchauffement dans les villes
on parle beaucoup maintenant de verdir
la ville pour pour la tempérer on sait
que le les arbres en ville les espaces
verts en ville permettent de tempérer de
vue de faire la ville devenir respirable
parce que à continuer comme cela
les villes la vie en ville deviendra
insupportable
merci beaucoup joël labbé d'avoir
répondu à nos questions directes sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur écologiste du morbihan